[Music]
so let's talk about some of the
specifics here so I wanted to go to one
that I think we disagree I want you to I
want you to make the most compelling
case that you can this open borders
stuff yes okay I'm not an open borders
guy this is a I'm not a crazy borders
person whatever that means I don't I
don't think I don't think there should
be no immigration we are a nation of
immigrants that's what's made this
melting pot I think the greatest nation
in the history of the world that's
giving more freedom to more people than
than anyone ever but the open border
situation especially now in 2018 2018
strikes me as particularly tenuous like
take it away yeah good so I think one
thing to keep in mind is what exactly an
advocate of open borders is arguing for
so I think most so open borders is maybe
a bit of a misnomer it's more like
borders or porous borders or something
like that where so the idea wouldn't be
that there's perhaps no checkpoints or
no restrictions on immigration just very
few so I think most open border folks
would be happy saying that if you are a
wanted violent criminal that might
exclude you from immigrating if you have
some particularly deadly contagious
disease and so forth but other than that
for ordinary peaceful migrants should be
able to come to the United States as far
as the argument goes I think there
really two strands one is just that the
the economic benefits of immigration are
huge so the most optimistic estimates
say that we could potentially double
world GDP by opening border so we've
done a pretty good job opening up trade
we've done a much worse job opening up
borders but in terms of the productivity
gains it would be incredible better than
anything else we could do and this goes
back to what I was discussing earlier
with our obligations to the global poor
foreign aid doesn't have a good track
record military intervention doesn't
have a good track record but allowing
people to move from places with low
wages to higher wages is by far the best
anti-poverty tool that we have so if we
were going to get into the nitty-gritty
of some of that what do you actually
have to do then to secure the borders
right because that's really what this is
about so even if if you make every
economic argument that I'm like all
right I can
riddled my way out of that yeah right
like if I'm on board that you still have
to do something to make sure that you're
doing those things making sure that
murderers aren't coming in and all that
and we don't seem very good at that and
I think maybe that's the leap that gets
me to where I can't make the the
secondary part that you're talking about
here yeah so I'm not sure about the
policy specifics I mean something like
the old Ellis Island system seems pretty
good I mean we had a ton of immigration
back then but there still was some kind
of checking mechanism so as far so I
doubt that that involves building a wall
but having some kind of you know
centralized location where immigrants
can come and get documents and things
like that seems seems pretty reasonable
but that's probably the most detail I
could give you on policy ideas right so
then when you go over these borders then
your gut you would want these people to
be governed by the laws of the place
that they were in right Act that's right
yeah yeah so so I would be happy to to
write a ordinarily peaceful migrants to
come in and then apply for US
citizenship just you know make it pretty
easy to do that right is this though a
tough one for a guy that doesn't trust
the government that much because that
that's what's ringing with me here and
when I've heard this argument it's like
all right wait if you don't trust the
government well then why do you think
the government would be able to vet
people properly especially because we
now see what's going on in Europe where
they've vetted people very poorly and
have had very porous borders yeah so
this might yeah so I don't know I think
though if you're a skeptic of the
government so presumably you're a
free-trade advocate you like the other
cross borders you wouldn't be happy with
government's micromanaging trade across
borders because you know skeptic about
how all the government works as am i and
for the same sorts of reasons I'm
skeptical so I think if you're worried
about the government working well that's
all the more reason to get it out of the
immigration regulation business so Mike
I think you're probably right
there's a bad job of a lot of stuff
almost everything and so the standard
here is not going to be perfection but
just what's the best alternative heavily
regulated immigration or lightly
emigrated regulation and I think all
things equal lightly and lightly
regulated immigration will probably be
better
let me give you another argument too so
this again is maybe a more libertarian
classical liberal argument for
immigration but it just seems like
people have a right to move across
borders so for example if you know I
don't know this table for example were
divided by some kind of border and I
said well look I want you to come over
to my side and rent my house from me or
work in my business or join my religious
congregation and you said okay I do want
to do those things and we both agree on
this we agree on the terms and then the
state sort of intervenes is a third
party in this what this philosopher
Robert knows who could call a capitalist
act between consenting adults it seems
like they would be violating our rights
to associate with one another among
three terms and so I think there's a
reason to think that border controls
violate people's natural rights is there
also some inherent problem though that
let's say most of the Western societies
the freest societies got on board this
well then they would end up being
flooded with people where maybe the
economics don't work out because if we
just say I mean if you think about it
like if tomorrow we were dressed like
alright everybody can come and yeah as
long as you're not a murderer or you
know drug dealer you're good to go
that there must be some economic theory
here where we're gonna let in a certain
amount of people your economics are
gonna work out and then we're gonna get
to some odd tipping point where because
freedom is pretty good people go on in
on it yeah so I think there are a couple
things to say so one is just if we I
think that problem to some extent would
be self-correcting so if you think that
a lot of the pressure to migrate is
economic so people are moving from
low-wage countries to higher wage
countries well as you have more and more
people answer about high wage higher
wage countries this would increase the
total number of workers which would
probably start dropping down their wages
and so you would probably see less
motivation to move I think that's one
thing but as a concession to this worry
what I would say is we could do it
slowly so for example if we're really
worried about these effects of
dramatically increasing immigration
overnight what we could do is just say
increase say the limits on immigration
by 10 percent every year or something
like that
and take it slowly and see where it goes
we wouldn't have to push the button open
the borders overnight if we have this
worried yeah what do you think is
philosophically the the soundest way to
deal with the people that are already
here I yeah so I am an advocate of the
view that you don't have an obligation
to obey unjust laws and so I think that
our immigration laws are unjust so I
think people who came here even against
current immigration law I think they
should just um Amnesty pull citizenship
that's that would be my approach to that
huh yeah all right we're not quite there
let me ask you this so you're not a fan
of the drug war no I'm not okay so
suppose we have somebody who I don't
know is in jail for selling marijuana
yeah like this and then suppose that
yeah so the break was a citizen of the
United broke say current immigration or
not immigration current drug laws yeah
do you think that they violated some
moral obligation that they had not to
break the u.s. drug law or do you say
well look it was a bad law so they
didn't do anything
well well partly I think it would depend
on the specific offense so so whether
they were using drugs or selling drugs I
would see a distinction there so okay if
there's someone that and there are
people that are in jail for using drugs
right now for using pot I I think those
those laws are unjust and I would want
to do everything I could to reverse
those laws and reverse the the prison
system the justice system and all that
as far as the dealers
yeah you can't until until we fix these
laws and figure out what actually is
fair and change some classifications on
marijuana and a bunch of other things
it's tough I think it's tough I don't
think you can free drug dealers per se
okay even though you're gonna you don't
think they did something that should be
against the law the people that are
doing the drugs I think you have a right
to do with your body as you see fit but
okay but again if you break a law you
have to like I would change the laws is
what I'm saying but if you break a law
then you have to suffer the consequences
of that
so does that do that all again well but
I'm curious I don't know forgive me for
but so suppose you have a drug user
who's convicted of this offense yeah
they're they're in jail but suppose they
can escape from prison
harmlessly do you think they would be
doing something morally wrong by
escaping footbridge all right so this is
a good little all right we're doing a
little my students know this is great I
mean this is what it's about right so
okay so let's say someone was smoking
weed at home cops bust in they're thrown
in jail for three years year two and
they're gonna pull a Shawshank and get
out of there right do I think they're
morally the question is do I think
they're morally right for doing it or it
can that be morally justified yes so
right so would we morally criticize them
if right they pulled a Shawshank where
they escaped through the wall or
something like that and they don't harm
anyone they just they just leave because
they say I was convicted of something
that ought not be a crime so I don't owe
any morally moral allegiance to that law
and so I'm just going to escape would
you you know hear about this story do
you say I'd be rooting for that okay
yeah I would be rooting for that so
that's kind of my perspective on
immigration that I think that it's an
unjust law and so people just as people
aren't under an obligation to obey the
state with respect to the drug war yeah
I don't think people are under an
obligation told me the state with
respect to immigration right so I guess
our sort of disconnected on this is just
the unjustness of immigration laws
versus drug laws right right so if you
think that the law itself is not unjust
then my argument won't have any kind of
grip on you yeah yeah I'm not saying our
immigration laws are just by the way I
just think that especially now also just
because of terrorism and people move and
just when you see what's going on with
Europe and and because it hasn't just
been people trying to get over for
humanitarian purposes there we know that
there's a lot of migrants and all sorts
of other people and then assimilation
problems and then welfare state problems
like it just seems like it's become this
massive thing that most of Europe would
probably do it very differently if they
could look back eight years ago right
yeah so as far as the terrorism point
goes I mean I think if somebody is is a
one to terrorists or suspected terrorist
that's a perfectly legitimate reason not
to not to allow the men I'm less
concerned about the the assimilation
concern the welfare state concern so as
far as the the assimilation where he
goes I mean a lot of the the evidence
I've seen suggests that the political
values of immigrants and especially
second generation American
is almost identical to the political
political values held by native-born
Americans and as far as the welfare
state concern goes I would say we have
lots of other freedoms that can
potentially increase the cost of the
welfare state and we're okay with people
exercising them so for example you know
I don't know we allow people to choose
their own profession for example in the
United States and so suppose you have a
student who says here's what I want to
do with my life I want to become a
philosopher you say well that's you know
I see career choice not a lot of money
in it who knows maybe you'll end up on
unemployment and this will in fact
increase the cost of the welfare state
because now you have this person on
unemployment because they chose to
become a philosopher with their life we
say well we let them do that we let them
exercise that freedom to choose their
occupation even knowing that this might
increase the costs of the welfare state
and so I think you can make an analogous
argument about immigration if you think
it's a right and important human freedom
then you say well this is sort of a
price of respecting rights and
respecting freedom they sometimes can
impose costs on third parties yeah so if
all these people come here then what
what duty does the state have to make
sure that they don't just get here and
can't do anything and then then more
crime comes and drugs and the rest of it
yeah is there a responsibility for the
state at that point I'm not sure that
the responsibility of the state to
immigrants is different from their
responsibility to citizens so I think
part so I mean there's also a question
of what we would do in the ideal world
versus the real world so you say in the
ideal world of somebody like Milton
Friedman the welfare state is much
smaller maybe you have something like
the negative income tax this isn't the
world we live in we have over a trillion
dollars of redistributed spending every
year I mean I don't so there are two
separate issues so one is this empirical
claim about whether immigrants tend to
consume more in government services than
they pay in taxes and it seems like the
fiscal effect is pretty moderate so some
estimates say they do in fact raise
fiscal costs a little bit others say no
in fact actually they're a net benefit
because a lot of a lot of new immigrants
aren't consuming a lot of government
services and so forth and they're paying
sales tax and things like this
but I think though again this is like
the concession if you really have this
way about the welfare say we could say
well maybe this is not my view but if if
this is what it took for me to get you
over to my side I'll give you this I'll
give you this concession we could say
something like you have a five-year
waiting period before you have access to
unemployment benefits and whatnot I
would take that over board or closure if
those are the only two operating it's
tough being intellectually honest isn't
it because you have to get you have to
concede things every now and again which
you just don't see people doing anymore
so it seems like doubly that's just this
is just a ploy to get you and your
viewers to the Lord on my side so yeah I
don't care so much about the honesty
just get people on the open border side
all right so you've argued that
inequality of income isn't the real
issue but poverty is the real issue
right let's get into the weeds on that
okay good so sometimes you'll hear this
is sometimes philosophers but oftentimes
politicians they'll make statements like
2% of American earners have 40% of that
country's wealth or something like that
and from here we're supposed to infer
that some injustice has occurred because
there's this this large enough quality
and I think I mean there might be an
injustice there but we can't tell
strictly on the basis of the inequality
so there's a philosopher named Robert
Nozick who famously said what matters
isn't so much the income distribution
that we end up with but how we got there
so if somebody has a huge amount of
wealth but they got it through theft or
they got it through lobbying the
government for special privileges this
is very bad this is something that we
shouldn't encourage on the other hand if
we have somebody who has a lot of wealth
because they invented the iPhone and
there are tens if not hundreds of
millions of people who want to buy this
that's totally fine so we can't just
look at the pie and how it's carved up
and say whether it's just or unjust we
have to see that people make their money
by making other people better off by
giving them things that they wanted or
did they take it through fraudulent
means coercive means and I think that
the talk about inequality oftentimes
confuses equality with poverty so is
what we're really concerned with
equalizing income or are we concerned
about making the poll
or better off and I think it's the
latter that we really should care about
so how do we go ahead and do that well
so opening borders I think is the first
step in terms of alleviating global
inequality or I'm sorry global poverty I
think is the best thing that we can do I
think domestically there are a lot of
government policies that really do harm
to the most disadvantaged groups so I
think opening up school choice would be
a great idea I think I think the drug
war would be a great idea I think ending
occupational licensing would be a very
good idea so enabling people to work in
certain industries or start their own
business with a lot less red tape is a
very good and wouldn't barbers be
stabbing people with scissors there are
some states where you have to you have
to get a license to shampoo people yeah
but I shampoo my shampoo my hair every
morning you're doing this unless you
know it's and I probably shouldn't say
that yeah I do
I should myself like you know comb my
hair without a license and so far the
government hasn't come after me and I
haven't you know poked my eye out yeah
so what's your all right so what's your
best argument that when when the people
that don't buy into this and say well we
need these regulations because you're
gonna have people that don't know how to
dye hair are gonna be scalding people's
heads and you know mr. burns is gonna be
dumping nuclear waste into the
Springfield River and all of those
things yeah that's the best argument
against me well so one argument is just
that I don't think regulation works very
well and I don't think so I think the
way that the public views regulation is
probably misguided so I don't think the
regulator's are bad people but I think
if you examine the ways that regulations
are formed and operate in the real world
it's oftentimes to protect the interests
of the industries that they're
regulating so this is what's known as
regulatory capture where regulators
aren't always looking out for the public
interest they're actually looking out
for the interest of people in that
industry so financial regulation is the
case of this you have lobbyists who
might be friends with people in the
financial sector they want to work in
the financial sector later or vice versa
and so they're often very friendly to
the very people that they're regulating
and as far as you know the the worry
about you know scalding people and so
forth I think that competition itself is
a kind of regulation so in the case of
school choice it
true you might have very bad charter
schools for example but again the the
standard here is not perfection the
standard is what's the alternative so we
have public schools that are terrible
yeah but charter schools have this
advantage of enabling people to choose
so if you go to a charter school that's
failing you can pull your kids out and
put them somewhere else and that's a
kind of regulation in the sense that it
provides incentives to the providers to
supply good service so it's almost like
we should rely on self-regulation yeah
yeah not even self regulation in the
sense so this is something that comes up
when I when I argue with people is they
think that I have this view of private
business as as being sort of benevolent
where they'll just take care of
themselves out of a sense of the public
interest I think maybe to some extent
that's true but it's more the kind of
Smithey and insight where if you have
providers who are competing for my
business they don't have to care about
my welfare directly or the welfare of my
family but they might just want my money
and that itself is an incentive for them
to provide good safe service so in a
sense it's competition for dollars
competition for customers that acts as
the regulation so I think the market as
a whole is self-regulating or
self-correcting yeah so you're also a
universal basic income supporter yeah
now usually this is a idea that comes
from economists on the left I've heard
some interesting sort of libertarian
arguments from it from people but what
is your take on so this goes back to the
idea that it is important to take care
of people who are in poverty or who
might have fallen on hard luck and need
some help getting back on their feet I
pitch for the universal basic income
would just be suppose you could take I
forget what the number is but you know
over a trillion dollars of redistributed
spending that the United States
government does Social Security Medicare
Medicaid unemployment all these things
suppose we said ok you can remove all
that and just get some kind of cash
payout if you fall below a certain level
of poverty so this is kind of the Milton
Friedman idea where you get sort of more
and more money the further below the
poverty line you are so you can take the
whole apparatus of the welfare state
with its bureaucracy and inefficiency
and just replace that with the universal
basic income I make that trade every day
of the week yeah do you think that that
would disincentivize people - actually
the people that are right above that
marker I mean do you know where you put
that markers so I don't know I don't
have the specifics of where I would put
it but yeah the idea is that we so the
way that Friedman structured the idea of
the negative income tax is that you
would still get more total income by
working and making more money so you
would see some decrease in the cash
branch that you get from the government
but it wouldn't be so massive as to
disincentive it so they would be trend
but they wouldn't be trimmed so much
that you have no incentive to go to work
yeah do you see that as just like some
sort of inconsistency with the way that
you generally view government because
like it's you're obviously not a big
government guy right and yet this is
something that's really like I would
view this as something that this is like
government should have no place in
giving that much to people like it's
kind of shitty like I'd love to figure
out better ways to help people who need
it the most but the idea of giving more
I just don't know that there's evidence
that it works yeah so there so I think
though that if that objection is
successful would also be successful
about against something like private
charity for example so I think there
always is this worry that when you give
some kind of assistance that this will
have negative effects on people's
incentives to work I think that's I
think that's probably true to some
extent but that might just be a cost
that we have to live with so I think
again even if you're doing some sort of
private charity that might lessen at the
margin people's willingness to go to
work but I think that trade-off is worth
it if it means say that we have people
who aren't starving who aren't very sick
without help but I do I so again a
concession that I will make because I
think by and large private charity will
work much better than sort of state
bureaucratic charity yeah
or transfer programs and some
philosophical level doesn't that also
make people feel better like the idea
that like right now the government just
does things and it either does them
inefficiently or not you don't really
know where your money's going and
you kind of just are like you can just
easily be like yeah I'm for poor people
because the government's doing it right
where when you actually go ahead and do
things and go ahead and volunteer and go
ahead and give charity and all that that
just philosophically for your own
goodness and happiness and things that
we've talked about that that's probably
much more rewarding I think so
right it's very it's very easy and
low-cost to just cast a vote for some
policy or politician that happens to
align with your values that doesn't
really you know the price of that is
very low but right actually say doing
some research figuring out what causes
you support putting money to those
things right I think that's much more
gratifying I think you should get more
immortal credit for doing that just
voting for policies that you like - is
that sort of the basic disconnect
between Democrats and Republicans at
this point like I view it as sort of
Democrats are kind of like we'll just do
everything for you we're gonna say all
the nice things and do it for you and
Republicans are just like we're not we
all they end up doing it anyway because
once they're in power they're always
spending the money anyway but they seem
like the evil guys cuz they don't want
to do it then they do it anyway but
that's what it really comes down to it's
like one set of people who are saying
we're gonna do all the nice things and
then doing them even when the results
aren't nice and another set who doesn't
don't say they want to do the nice
things but then they end up doing it the
results still aren't great yeah well so
so I'm not sure although I do remember
this book is probably a little old by
now called who really cares by Arthur
Brooks have you ever come across
so he's I think now he's the president
and I don't know right and what he did
find that there were differences in
charitable giving between Democrats and
Republicans or I'm not sure if it was
along party lines or ideological lines
more broadly and he did find evidence
that conservatives tend to give more
privately than Democrats there might be
a variety of explanations for that so
one explanation might just be that
conservatives tend to be more skeptical
of this the efficacy of these
large-scale
bureaucracies like how well do they
actually work I think there's maybe also
this this idea that it's the role of
something like the family or the church
or civil society to take care of people
who are in poverty rather than the
states and so maybe that's why you see
conservatives giving more charitable
dollars than people on the left yeah all
right so I want to finish up with a
couple
scientific experiments okay you've
you've written about oh wow I got a
couple here all right let's see how how
sharp you are on the previous work
you've done all right talk to me about
the Stanford Prison Experiment okay yeah
so oh man that's yeah that's going back
right so this was this was research
around here I don't just sit down with
people in you know I think you know my
work better than that yeah so that was
an experiment that was conducted I want
to say in the early 70s by a Stanford
psychologist and he recruited more or
less ordinary young men to serve in this
experiment and some of the subjects were
cast as prisoners in this fake prison
and other subjects were cast as the
prison guards in this experiment and so
they were enforcing the prison rules and
feeding the prisoners and having them go
to sleep at specified times and so forth
and to make a long story short what he
found was that the power given to the
students who were the prison guards did
have this corrupting effect so this idea
that power corrupts and absolute power
corrupts absolutely seem to be supported
by his experiments so very quickly a
think in a matter of days what you found
were the guards again were drawn from
the same demographic pool as the as the
prisoners were abusing the prisoners
were mocking them and he had to cut it
short because essentially the wheels
came off of this experiment and the
prisoners got so abuse that prison
guards got so abusive and so this I
think confirms this idea that you don't
have to be a bad person
to allow power to have this corrupting
effect on your behavior yeah there must
be plenty of other studies proving that
right even through just the prison
system I mean I feel like every prison
movie I've ever watched our orange is
the new black I mean the people that are
in charge of the prisons usually are
pretty bad people yeah yeah and like I
said they could be perfectly ordinary
and there's also the the Milgram
experiments were which are kind of the
the classic case of this where you just
have people who are in essence willing
to torture give electric shocks to
complete strangers because somebody in
authority told them to do so and the
subjects figure out ways to rationalize
why these electric shocks are justified
may you know the person should behave
differently
they wouldn't have gotten the shocks and
what's really frightening about this is
it does show that ordinary people people
like you know you and I could easily see
our behavior corrupted given the right
sort of institutions yeah what do you do
as a human knowing that what do you do
to insulate your saying yeah well so one
thing I think is to be very skeptical of
these sorts of institutions which give
people lots of power over others I think
that's one of the big picture lessons
from these sorts of experiments is just
be wary of giving people power on an
individual level knowing about it I
think helps a little bit but even more
than just knowing about it I think
practicing it so when you know that
you're in a position say you to do
something wrong because you feel the
social pressure to do it on a small
level just try to resist that impulse
and actually do the right thing so I
don't think it's the sort of thing that
you can condition yourself to do
overnight to resist malevolent Authority
or resist becoming a malevolent
authority but you could take small steps
but kind of it's like practicing an
athletic skill or something like that
you don't try dunking a basketball the
first time you pick it up but you take
these small incremental steps and you
get better and better
hopefully you build character traits and
then maybe resist it when the situation
becomes more dire it's interesting
because that sort of reminds me of the
way that we see virtue signaling
happening on social media these days
it's not that we're all deciding we have
this power and we can shock somebody but
it's like you find someone halfway
across the world who says something you
slightly disagree with even though
you've never heard of them before you
start seeing the mob go at them and the
next thing you know you ratchet up more
and then someone else ratcheted up more
and watch that more and it's all done in
the name of being good actually the way
you're trying to shame and destroy this
person yeah they're in there right
there's something kind of
psychologically gratifying about being
part of a moralizing mob and I think
that's an impulse that does have to be
resisted right so it's for two signaling
it's not after it's not you over exactly
actual virtue would be saying something
like well I you know I think everybody
here is wrong about what the right thing
to do is here yeah that's a usually a
pretty lonely guy it's true that's true
all right one more sure the Asch
conformity experience yeah
so that's along the same line as the
Stanford Prison Experiment and the
Milgram experiments in this I think this
was the
one of the originals it was in the 1950s
and subjects were given a board which
had lines of different lengths on them
so like there was one that was very long
one that was moderately long one that
was short for example and then they were
given another line that they were told
was the same length as one of the lines
on the other board and it was very
obvious so it was like this was a like a
very long line over here and there was a
very long line over here they were
clearly the same length but they were
surrounded by other lines of various
lengths but it was this is very easy
test and so they asked subjects well
which line over here is the same length
as this line over here and everybody
knew what the correct answer was but the
twist of the experiment was the
experimenter would bring in Confederates
who would lie and give the obviously
false answer so they would say oh in
fact it turns out that this short line
over here is the same length as this
long line over here and what they wanted
to test was whether the genuine subject
would conform to the mistaken group
judgement which they need to be clearly
wrong or would they stick to their guns
and say no everybody in this room is
wrong it's clearly you know this line
here and everybody else made a mistake
and the depressing result is that many
people would not just conform once but
would conform over and over again to the
judgment the thing it was wrong and even
people who sometimes broke from the
group would have at least a couple of
answers where they conforms to the group
answer so is that just sort of basic
built in DNA that just certain people
are gonna stand up for what they believe
in what's right and what's true and and
just most of us aren't or is that can
you community been Pinker class yeah
well I believe Pinker would say
something about a blank slate Yeah right
so I'm not sure right he might he might
say it's something close to our DNA I'm
not sure it's interesting when you read
testimony from people in the Milgram
experiments there were some people who
just refused to deliver these shocks to
people even though there was a lot of
pressure on them and it seems like some
of them had life experiences that really
discourage them from obeying the
authority and it wouldn't shock me no
pun intended if there was something like
that going on in these conformity
experiments
maybe people have seen the malevolent
effects of blind conformity and this
motivated them to do it so yeah so I'm
not sure whether its nature or nurture I
don't know it's probably about my
paygrade
right so all right as long as you
mentioned Pinker this is I think will be
a good way to wrap this all up are you
hopeful as as a philosopher are you
hopeful for free thought I mean a lot of
people that care about the conversations
that we're having are really worried and
I find that the people that are most
closely associated with that I have
these conversations with most I would
say most of us are sort of world weary
optimists that's how I would describe
myself like if I wasn't hopeful I don't
know how the hell I could do this every
day right I'm hopeful that we can make
things better and yet at the same time
there's no doubt we have an uphill
battle and that there's you know so much
hysteria all the time and all the forces
that that were not in to seem to be on
the march all the time but are you
hopeful I like that term world-weary
optimist I think that probably describes
me pretty well and part of the reason
I'm optimistic is because oftentimes
when I think when you're interacting
with people on a one-on-one level you
know you're more likely to have a civil
productive discussion about
controversial topics then when it's like
these huge like I you just gave this
talk I think recently at a college and
you've got university New Hampshire you
okay right yeah and so I think in those
so talking about like virtue signaling
and a mob mentality I think those sorts
of settings are conducive to that I
think oftentimes when you're just
talking with a person over a beer you
might have completely different politics
than they do but it's kind of a
non-threatening sort of friendly
situation I think people's guards go
down a little bit more in those sorts of
situations and you can actually have a
conversation about controversial topics
in good faith and so that so I think
people want that I think people want to
have these kinds of discussions the
arguments and it might be the people who
are least friendly to that sort of thing
get the most visibility or get the most
publicity but I think you know if you
took an average purse
off the street and said hey let's grab a
beer and talk about politics it wouldn't
be nearly as bad as you know doing it in
front of 50,000 people I agree and
that's why I said the thing about the
80% before and I think in summation you
believe that beer is the great
philosophical equalizer
maybe bourbon I'm not really there's no
I got this great thing over here so yeah
so bourbon is bourbon whiskey that yeah
on that note we should wrap this up and
see what we can do with the bourbon all
right for more on Chris check out see
Fryman dot-com which will link to right
down below
[Music]
you